hello and welcome this video ever called
Leah cornea this is a frequent alone and
I played him quite a bit to see a is
placer that the net shock I just go Ford
you for now trying for something
different
probably you will build up a head shock
anyway no no no Hedgehog and get
something that is kind of comparable to
tirage tirage Queen's Gambit I have to
move a 3 plate which is not not that
great and I mean not that great it's not
helping let's say on the other hand the
early capture on deform and it's not
that brilliant for black either
okay so prolly castles yeah I have to
make sure I have to develop my bishop
somewhere maybe I can take here and play
Bishop III yep yeah I think taking with
the pawn is kind of right so that you at
least get something with the rook after
Queen takes White is just better form
yeah but it's just better without
anything special but I can it's
debatable maybe it's probably some
advantage anyway so should you form just
this yeah the last game this was was
again something where just lost you to
my bad time management so again a
conscious effort of playing playing
quicker so okay let's get United traded
okay me can go back of course to the
six for example 93 Bishop c5 just drops
material yeah and I think I thought
night of 3 years of that ultimately the
night comes to deform and putting the
Queen on B - yeah I'm sacrificing maybe
some quality of Musa for the sake of
being quicker but the last game again
was pretty pretty annoying where the
opponent was very simply our plate but
then I screwed things up
night is not bad on these three anyway
so I don't mind you - yeah - to gain the
tempo on the Queen no not a four net
before those are interesting piece
placements check yeah just trade stuff
yeah why not if I go f3 now and check on
f6 this is any good looks very weakening
on the dark squares mm-hmm I'm not sure
about this
f3 Knight d6 mmm don't like that I like
a good structure but not sure I wonder
night before Knight f4 maybe Knight f4
I couldn't see one assistant idea tried
to invade it's a nice position but but
how do you win it was also not sure I'm
not sure if I should go before or not
maybe I should have gone before okay I'm
going to we're going to win de win this
time now take this this time when that
same time gain sorry time witness
totally wrong expression I can also take
now here right
isn't this a tq5 huh okay you can't
check me but it's just one check so
let's let's grab stuff black resigns no
okay playing quicker sometimes really
helpful yeah that was a I think a pretty
bad position out of the opening this is
certainly some some kind of theoretical
line we should be six well no I went a
94 I already don't like blacks position
to be honest if I get to take on B 6 I
mean you can do that but this is not
really my 95 or Bishop III c5 know why
this is certainly a bit better than this
is already I mean I think that this is
not a good idea that we grew up in yeah
now b3 kicking that out back yeah I know
I'm I did this regrouping the queenís
noise there it was just running into
all those temp science chat and yeah at
night
yeah the f3 was also interesting and now
a three I think is is probably just
winning the game like this and over you
can click with the Queen but oops
but this it's not helping ultimately I'm
a porn herb this is hanging and all
pawns a week so that's also win yeah
there was nice
nice game thanks for watching